MEETING OF THE SEASON.
UP, BACK
HAND PASS BLOCKED.
RAKELL IN DEEP.
HE'S OUTNG WRIST SHOT SCORE!
NEW CAREER
WATCH QUICK LITTLE SHOT AND ROY
CHANDLER
STEPHENSON'S GOALINE.
COMING OFF
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS WILL HAVE AW.
SMITH COUPLE OF STEPS IN.
SAVEN.
>> CUSTOM
F
SEASON. THE BY
SMITH WILL WAS-COAST.
YOU CAN SEAMANSON TURNS AWAY
FROM THE PUCK.
THAT
AWAY.HE SETS UP SCORE!
IT BACK TOWARDSTHE NHL.
PATRICK TURNS IT THING, GOLDEN
KNIGHTS ABILITY TO SCORE OFF THE
RUSH.BEEN UNDER SIEGE
YEAR.
MARCHESSAULT BEATS AND IN THE L.
MILANO BREAKS UP ICE WITHBLE MAM
FOR ONE FINAL RUSH ON THE POWER.
QUICK SHOT AND RIGHT TOOUPLE OF.
HIS SHOT, SAVE GIBSON.TAINED
-THIS GAME.
MARCHESSAULT.
SMITH BODY,LAURENT BROSSOIT, HU
RACKELL THE OTHER WAY
CARRICK GOES IN.
GOOD LITTLE BODY POSITION PLAY
ON PIETRANGLO IN JUST A THE WAL
AND OFF OF GETZLAFAF
GOOD JOB BY GETZLAF.
HE KICKS THAT
MICHAEL AMADIO, WHAT A CHANCE A
MOMENT AGO. UP
AHEAD.
THAT HIT
LITTLE BANK FOR CARRIER.
WITH DADONOV ANDNLY THING LEFT
THIS GAME WAS COULD LAURENT
SCRAMBLE PLAY.
CE